[Music]
some of you may have seen in school that
the surface area of a sphere is 4 pi r
squared a suspiciously suggestive
formula given that it's a clean multiple
of the more popular pi r squared the
area of a circle with the same radius
but have you ever wondered why this is
true and i don't just mean proving the
four pi r squared formula i mean
viscerally feeling to your bones a
connection between this surface area and
these four circles
how lovely would it be if there was some
subtle shift in perspective that shows
how you could nicely and perfectly fit
these four circles onto the sphere's
surface
nothing can be quite that simple since
the curvature of a sphere surface is
different from the curvature of a flat
plane which is why trying to fit say a
piece of paper around the sphere it it
just doesn't work
nevertheless i would like to show you
two separate ways of thinking about the
surface area that connect it in a
satisfying way to these circles
the first comes from a classic one of
the true gems of geometry that i think
all math students should experience the
same way all english students should
read at least some shakespeare the
second line of reasoning is something of
my own which draws a more direct line
between the sphere and its shadow
and lastly i'll share why this four-fold
relation is not unique to spheres but is
instead one specific instance of a much
more general fact for all convex shapes
in three
dimensions starting with the bird's eye
view here the idea for the first
approach is to show that the surface
area of the sphere is the same as the
area of a cylinder with the same radius
and the same height as that sphere
or rather a cylinder without the top and
the bottom what you might call the label
of that cylinder
and once you have that you can unwrap
that label to understand it simply as a
rectangle
the width of this rectangle comes from
the cylinder's circumference so it's 2
pi times r
and the height comes from the height of
the sphere which is 2 times the radius
and this already gives us the formula 4
pi r squared when we multiply the two
but in the spirit of mathematical
playfulness it's nice to see how four
circles with radius r can actually fit
into this picture
the idea will be to unwrap each circle
into a triangle without changing its
area and then to fit those nicely into
the unfolded cylinder label more on that
in a couple minutes the more pressing
question is why on earth should the
sphere be related to the cylinder in
this way
the way i'm animating it is already
suggestive of how this might work
the idea is to approximate the area of
the sphere with many many tiny
rectangles covering it and to show how
if you project these rectangles directly
outward as if casting a shadow by little
lights positioned on the z-axis pointing
parallel to the x y plane the projection
of each rectangle onto the cylinder
quite surprisingly ends up having the
same area as the original rectangle
but why should that be
well there are two competing effects at
play here for one of these rectangles
let's call the side along the latitude
lines its width and the side along the
longitude lines its height
on the one hand as the rectangle is
projected outward its width will get
scaled up
for rectangles towards the poles that
length is scaled up quite a bit since
they're projected over a longer distance
but for those closer to the equator the
effect might be close to nothing
but on the other hand because these
rectangles already slant with respect to
the z direction during this projection
the height of each such rectangle will
get scaled down
think about holding some flat object and
looking at its shadow as you reorient
that object the shadow looks more or
less squished for some angles
now take a look those rectangles towards
the poles are quite slanted this way so
their height is going gonna get squished
down by a lot
for those closer to the equator oriented
somewhere closer to parallel to the
z-axis
the effect it's not as much
it will turn out that these two effects
of stretching the width and squishing
the height cancel each other out
perfectly
already as a rough sketch wouldn't you
agree that this is a very pretty way of
reasoning of course the meat here comes
from showing why these two competing
effects cancel each other out
and in some ways the details fleshing
this out are just as pretty as the
zoomed out structure of the full
argument so let's dig in
let me go ahead and cut away half of the
sphere so that we can get a better look
for any mathematical problem solving it
never hurts to start by giving things
names so let's say that the radius of
the sphere is r
and for one specific rectangle let's
call the distance between that rectangle
and the z-axis d
you could rightfully complain that the
distance d is a little ambiguous
depending on which point of that
rectangle you're going from
but for tinier and tinier rectangles
that ambiguity will become negligible
and tinier and tinier is when this
approximation with rectangles gets
closer to the true surface area anyway
to choose an arbitrary standard let's
say that d is the distance from the
bottom of the rectangle
now to think about projecting this out
to the cylinder what we're going to do
is picture two similar triangles the
first one shares its base with the base
of the rectangle on the sphere and has a
tip at the same height but on the z axis
a distance d away
the second triangle is a scaled up
version of this scaled so that it just
barely reaches the cylinder meaning its
long side now has a length r
so the ratio of their bases which is how
much our rectangle's width gets
stretched out is
r divided by d
what about the height how precisely does
that get scaled down as we project
again let's slice a cross-section for a
cleaner view and in fact why don't we go
ahead and completely focus our view to
this two-dimensional cross-section
to think about the projection let's make
a little right triangle like this
where what was the height of our
spherical rectangle is the hypotenuse
and the projection is one of the legs
pro tip any time you're doing geometry
with circles or spheres keep in the
forefront of your mind that anything
tangent to the circle is perpendicular
to the radius drawn to that point of
tangency
it's crazy just how helpful that one
little fact can be for making progress
in our case once we draw that radial
line together with the distance d we
have another right triangle
and often in geometry i like to imagine
tweaking the parameters of a setup and
imagining how the relevant shapes change
this helps to make guesses about what
the relations might be
in this case you might predict that the
two triangles i've drawn are similar to
each other since their shapes seem to
change in concert with each other
this is indeed true but as always don't
take my word for it see if you can
justify this for yourself
again it never hurts to give more names
to things maybe let's call this angle
alpha and this other one beta
since this is a right triangle we know
that alpha plus beta plus 90 degrees
must be 180 degrees
now let's zoom in on our little triangle
and see if we can figure out what its
angles might be
notice this 90 degree angle which comes
from the radius being perpendicular to
the tangent and how when it's combined
with this beta here and some other
little angle it forms a straight line
so that other little angle must be alpha
and this lets us fill out a few more
values which reveals that this little
triangle also has angles alpha beta and
90 degrees so it is indeed similar to
the big one
deep in the weeds like this it's
sometimes easy to forget why we're doing
this remember what we want to know is
how much the height of the sphere
rectangle gets squished down as we
project it out and that's the ratio of
this little hypotenuse to the leg on the
right side by the similarity with the
big triangle the ratio of those two
sides is again r divided by d
so indeed as this rectangle gets
projected outward the effect of
stretching out the width is perfectly
cancelled out by how much that height is
getting squished due to the slant
as a fun side note you might notice that
it looks like the projected rectangle is
a 90 degree rotation of the original
this would not at all be true in general
but by a lovely coincidence the way i'm
parametrizing the sphere results in
rectangles where the ratio of the width
to the height starts out as d to r
so for this very specific case rescaling
the width by r over d and rescaling the
height by d over r actually does have
the effect of a 90 degree rotation
and this lends itself to a rather
bizarre way to animate the relation
where instead of projecting each
rectangular piece as if casting a shadow
you can rotate each one of them 90
degrees and then rearrange them all to
make the cylinder
now if you're really thinking critically
you might still not be satisfied that
this shows us what the surface area of
the sphere is because all of these
little rectangles only approximate the
relevant areas
well the idea is that this approximation
gets closer and closer to the true value
for finer and finer coverings and since
for any specific covering the sphere
rectangles have the same area as the
cylinder rectangles whatever value each
of these two series of approximations
are approaching must actually be the
same
i mean as you get really aggressively
philosophical about what we even mean by
surface area these sorts of rectangular
approximations are not just aids in our
problem-solving toolbox they end up
serving as a way to rigorously define
the idea of area in the context of
smooth curved surfaces
this kind of reasoning is essentially
calculus just without any of the jargon
in fact i think neat geometric arguments
like this which require no background in
calculus to understand can serve as a
great way to tee things up for new
calculus students so that they have the
core ideas already in their head before
seeing the definitions which make them
precise rather than going the other way
around
alright so as i said before if you're
the kind of person who's just itching to
see a direct connection to these four
circles one nice way to do that is to
unwrap those circles into triangles
if this is something you haven't seen
before i go into much more detail about
why this works in the first video of the
calculus series the basic idea is to
relate thin concentric rings of the
circle with horizontal slices of this
triangle
because the circumference of each such
ring increases linearly in proportion to
the radius always 2 pi times that radius
when you unwrap them all and line them
up like this their ends will form a
straight line as opposed to some other
curved shape which gives us a triangle
with base two pi r and height r
and four of these unwrapped circles fit
perfectly into our rectangle which is in
some sense an unwrapped version of the
sphere's surface
now that's pretty satisfying but you
might nevertheless be wondering if
there's some way to relate this sphere
directly to a circle with the same
radius rather than going through this
intermediary of a cylinder
i do have a proof for you to this effect
leveraging a little trigonometry though
i have to admit i still think the
comparison to the cylinder wins out on
raw elegance now i'm a big believer that
the best way to really learn math is to
do problems for yourself which is a bit
hypocritical coming from a channel
essentially consisting of lectures so
i'm going to try something a little
different here and present the proof as
a heavily guided sequence of exercises
yes i know that's less fun and it means
you have to pull out some paper to do a
little work but i guarantee you will get
more out of it this way
at a high level the approach will be to
cut the sphere into many thin rings
parallel to the x y plane and to compare
the area of these rings to the area of
their shadows on the x-by-plane
all of the shadows of the rings from say
the northern hemisphere make up a circle
with the same radius as the sphere right
well the main idea will be to show a
correspondence between these ring
shadows and every second ring on the
sphere
challenge mode here is to pause now and
see if you can predict how that
comparison might go
let's label each one of these rings
based on the angle theta between a line
from the sphere's center to that ring
and the z axis
so theta ranges from 0 at the north pole
all the way up to 180 degrees at the
south pole which is to say from zero to
pi radians
and let's call the change in the angle
from one ring to the next d theta which
means the thickness of those rings will
be the radius r times d theta
all right structured exercise time will
ease in with a warm up question number
one what is the circumference of this
ring say at the inner edge in terms of r
and theta
once you have that go ahead and multiply
the answer by the thickness r times d
theta to get an approximation for the
ring's area an approximation that will
get better and better as you chop up the
sphere more and more finely
and at this point if you know your
calculus you could integrate but our
goal is not just to find the answer it's
to feel the connection between the
sphere and its shadow so question number
two what is the area of the shadow of
one of these rings on the x y plane
again expressed in terms of r theta and
d theta
and for this one it might be helpful to
think back to that tiny little right
triangle we were talking about earlier
question number three and this is really
the heart of it each one of these rings
shadows has precisely half the area of
one of the rings on the sphere
it's not the one that's an angle theta
straight above it but another one
the question is which one
as a hint you might want to reference
some trig identities for this one
question number four i said at the
outset that there's a correspondence
between all of the shadows from the
northern hemisphere which make up a
circle with radius r and every second
ring on the sphere
use your answer to the last question to
spell out what exactly that
correspondence is
[Music]
and for question five bring it on home
why does this imply that the area of the
circle is exactly one-fourth the surface
area of the sphere particularly as we
consider thinner and thinner rings
if you want answers or hints i'm quite
sure that people in comments and on
reddit will have them waiting for you
and finally i would be remiss not to
make at least a brief mention of the
fact that the surface area of a sphere
is a very specific instance of a much
more general fact if you take any convex
shape and look at the average area of
all of its shadows averaged over all
possible orientations in 3d space
that average will be exactly one-fourth
the surface area of your shape
as to why this is true i'll have to
leave those details for another day
[Music]